I'm gonna start talking about Google
Play instant that was announced at GDC
and Google Play Instant is is all about
an instant gratification it's it's about
getting the user in your experience as
fast as possible in today's world you
can think like I send a message to my
mom
let her tried out this new game she
looks she opens the link she goes to the
Play Store she plays the install button
the game starts installing slowly and
slowly then she forgets she gets about a
game she goes to the oven there was the
the dinner cooking she complete gets
about the game she never opens the game
again now here's the thing if you think
about the abandonment bunbun rate like
the number of people starts installing
installing a game and actually play the
game is the number of people who don't
play the game at all forget about the
installation is very very high if you
think about the numbers probably higher
than the numbers you're thinking about
now now we are taking this problem here
at Google with Google Play instant and
in this new word I send a link to my mom
she opens the link and instead of going
to the Play Store she brought she starts
immediately into the game like few
seconds the game starts running and it's
downloading a native application with no
installation whatsoever so there's no
more friction there now my mom is
playing she forgets about dinner and it
happened quite a few times actually the
key points here are the code that is
being downloaded for a Google Play
instant application in game in our case
is native code no JavaScript in there or
visual machine
it's native code and it's it does have
access to almost everything that a
normal application ever has access to
and we're going to see examples now now
Matt from Zynga implemented instantly
and he's gonna talk about their
experience all right so hello my name is
Matt Simon I'm a senior technical
manager in Zynga strategic partnerships
group which basically means that I help
manage the relationships with our
platform and development partners such
as Google and here's what I'll be
talking about today so a friend gave you
a quick recap of what the platform is
all about but I'll cover why we're on
the platform and what really excites us
about about it so and then I'll show you
a quick look of each of the three
instant games we made and then I'll kind
of cover how we made them and go into a
few of the technical details and then I
will talk about some tea some key
takeaways and things to remember when
you're building your own isn't games and
there will be some time at the end
hopefully for questions so this is this
is basically this is why we're on the
platform this is what it's all about
there's a huge potential to boost your
installs for your game and to then get
your game seen by many more people who
may not have seen it or who may not get
the opportunity to see it so and you can
you know you can sidestep some of the
drop offs that you see when you acquire
users on the Play Store for example if
you have you know a really large game
you get that prompt you know if you're
not on Wi-Fi you may want to avoid
downloading this game on cellular so you
know all those things you know those are
friction points those are funnel
drop-offs so with instant you can really
sidestep those and you know also if
people aren't ready to commit to
downloading your game for whatever
reason maybe they they want to try it
out maybe they don't know what the full
experience is going to be you can give
them a trial so and in fact you don't
really have to acquire users from the
Play Store at all and that's one of the
really exciting things about this
platform is that you can kind of
creatively distribute these games under
channels that were unavailable for
mobile game distribution previously so
our goals getting started were to build
something that allows us to really
understand what development and
publishing looks like on this new
platform you know and and hopefully
we'll see the tangible benefits of of
actually making these products to our
you know Diu and installs so that that
was the main goal I'm the way we do that
is we really focus on getting the user
into the instant experience as quickly
as possible and then we show them you
know how fun the game is right up front
and then when we feel that they've
gotten you know a good sense of what the
full experience is going to be we try to
get them to install the full game from
within the instant game so let's talk
about what we built
we started with Zynga solitaire which is
a super simple solitaire game written in
Java with Android studio a pretty
standard solitaire game nothing too
special so this was an obvious choice
because it was a very simple game and we
wanted to get started with a simple use
case for learning the platform so for
Google Play instance we were able to fit
the entire game into the instant
experience so you can play it instantly
and if you want a new game we prompt you
to install so pretty straightforward and
this was you know a single developer
just me took me about three days to get
started and you know about a week after
that to have it ready for publishing so
then we wanted to expand a bit with one
of our top games words with friends too
so this is a very popular social word
tile game written in Java and C++ with
cocos2d X so for instance we took the
game solo series ladder which is the
game's single-player experience and we
made that the
so that you know players can really get
a taste of the full game what it's all
about just by clicking try now and you
play against bots and we drop you right
into the game board right away and you
experience the fun gameplay as quickly
as possible and once you beat a few
levels of the solo series you can
install the full game and the words with
friends team had two engineers working
on this for about a total of four weeks
so then we really wanted to challenge
ourselves and see what you know what
what can we do on the platform what's
possible so CSR 2 is an immersive 3d
Street racing game you know built in
unity it's got state-of-the-art graphics
relatively demanding high fidelity game
and you know we have a lot of really
fine attention to detail we work
directly with the car manufacturers to
get extremely detailed car models so the
full game is about 1.3 gigabytes so
fairly significant on the download size
but with instant we can ensure we get
maximum reach and and get players
excited before committing to that full
download so what we did was we did a
showroom experience and we're showcasing
a single car from the latest
downloadable content available in the
full game and you can explore the car in
full graphic fidelity you can spin
around the car you can scale it up and
down you can act it's actually
interactive you can open and close the
doors in the hood and generally see what
you're going to get in the full game as
far as the fidelity goes we also added
we also added AR mode which is a feature
available in the full game it's powered
by a R core and you know this is great
for getting really up close and personal
with the cars doing some fun stuff like
there's my Lamborghini parked next to my
other car and you know like put it I put
a Lamborghini on on my desk inside
because why not so so let's let's see
how each of these were done going
through depth here a little bit first
let's talk some about the requirements
of being on the Google Play Instant
platform so the most significant thing
that you're going to have to deal with
is that 10 Meg initial apk limit so
you're you're going it can it can also
be the hardest to overcome right so
which is why it's so important to focus
on the absolute core gameplay experience
that really you know captures what the
essence of the game is so you know you
can download as much as you want after
the game starts running but the initial
apk that you that users download has to
be under 10 Meg's so these experiences
run on Android L and above that's 5.0
and above if you use OpenGL ES for any
of your any of your graphics and if you
do 3d graphics if you use GL es it has
to be 2.0 3.0 is not supported yet and
yeah not having that that thing on the
lower left is actually pushed
notifications they are not available on
the platform so there's no obvious way
to re-engage your users so that's why we
kind of focus on getting the user into
instant and then as soon as they get a
sense for the gameplay we try to drive
them to install as quickly as possible
so you have a few other things like a
reduced set of permissions for example
you can't ask for you can't request
external storage permissions things like
that you need to use HTTPS for all of
your network calls and there's a few
Android API s that are not available
things like
you know getting persistent IDs and
stuff like that
and finally we when you build your game
you need to use a relatively recent
version of Gradle that supports the
instant app structures and features so
this is a little bit about solitaire you
may or may not be familiar with the
diagram on the side but this comes from
the Google Instant apps documentation
basically you have features which are
basically a unit of functionality or
gameplay and you're in your game or app
and then you have your instant app
module which depends on features and you
have your egg Euler app module so you
have a unified build that can actually
target both platforms instant and and
installable so for solitaire we're
actually able to refactor the Android
studio project into a simplified version
of of this diagram namely we were able
to fit the entire game into just a
single base feature which is not not
typical usually well you wouldn't have
your full game available as an instant
app usually but for this one it turned
out to be so small that we could put the
entire thing in there so the game was
already relatively small it's just a
standard solitaire game so you know we
enabled asset minification and a few
other settings and it fit pretty much
right into 8 megabytes so not too much
to worry about there one of the
challenges that I had to overcome when
doing this game was upgrading an older
Gradle build script actually a set of
older Gradle build scripts to the later
Gradle version and I hadn't had much
experience with Gradle before this and
there is a fairly large jump in
require changes between the two versions
so just getting familiar with all those
changes was really helpful in you know
getting familiar with the required
things you have to do to make an instant
app and also help with our other instant
apps that we did after solitaire and
then when I was ready to submit to the
alpha track on the Play console going
through the process was really helpful
because turns out when you submit an
instant app it'll probably tell you some
of the things that you might not have
done correctly for example supporting
Android app links and linking your your
app to your website that you own with a
digital asset links file so getting
those kind of those that whole process
understood really well was was really
helpful as well
so and then words with friends was
actually relatively easy which kind of
says a lot you know most of the work was
specific to the game into Zynga code not
too many dependencies on the instant app
runtime or Android so that was good
and we didn't really have to optimize it
that much you know removing some
unneeded SDKs things like that and when
when we focused on the core experience
which is that solo series we got to kind
of remove a whole bunch of other parts
of the game that contributed a lot to
the size especially with you know
texture atlases and game modes things
like that and when we removed all those
things it pretty much got us within
striking distance of the ten Meg limit
so when we started working on CSR to
this kind of summed up what we were
thinking not not not an obvious path
from one point three gigs down to ten
Meg's
but the solution was pretty much
the same as for other games which we
need we wanted to refocus on really the
core of the game what makes the game fun
or the essence of the full game and this
this image is is pretty accurate turns
out that we scaled down the game quite
extensively and we ripped we ripped out
most of it so originally what we were
going to do was a playable race from the
tutorial level but but we decided to
pare it down because it's not just about
the race it's actually what makes it fun
is all the other things like collecting
collecting your cars customizing them
seeing them in their extreme detail so a
showroom can do that and it was within
our grasp for the initial attempt at
this and that's kind of what we focused
on
and we basically removed absolutely
everything else from the game which was
quite a lot and we had a lot of fun
doing it as well we we had commit
messages that were like now down to
seven hundred Meg's and now down to four
hundred Meg's so we had some fun with it
so a few other things that we had to
keep in mind so the game relied pretty
heavily on Android expansion files these
are so-called OBB files because you know
your your apk can only be a hundred
Meg's I think or somewhere around there
obviously the bulk of it had to be in
the expansion files and because this is
all about
instant instant downloads relatively
instant you can't download several
hundred megabytes of data Oh babies are
not available on the platform so turns
out that we needed to completely react
attack the way that the game loaded
assets because there's not an
expectation of the assets of the OBB
file being there anymore so so it turns
out we we rewrote the asset loader to
load things locally from resources
the game used GL es 3 to render the cars
specifically needed a particular GL
extension that was more prevalent on
devices that supported GL es 3 and given
that the platform only supports GL ES 2
this is something we had to think about
we never really got around the issue
just due to lack of time and a few other
things but this was mainly a prototype
so fortunately we didn't have to really
worry about it
so and you know when building the game
unity outputs a Gradle project this
Gradle project has no idea what an
instant app is so this is something I
believe is being worked on but don't
quote me on it but for what we had to do
here we had to basically manually modify
the Gradle scripts add basically
references to all of the feature targets
the refactoring the modules this game
was relatively involved because it used
a lot of third-party libraries a lot of
native libraries so all of that had to
be tied into the Gradle set up so let's
yeah let's talk about a few things to
keep in mind when you're developing your
own instant games so one of the most
important things to keep in mind is to
keep things focused on the core of what
makes your game fun it really helps with
optimizing the size but it also ensures
the user is enjoying the experience
right from the get-go you know I I
forgot where but somebody said that you
know there's like a less than 10 second
window from when a user tries a brand
new game before they lose interest so if
you don't capture their excitement
within that 10 seconds then they might
lose interest
not sure how exactly true that is or how
you can verify it but there is clearly
something that you need to optimize for
so if your game loads data at runtime
might be a good idea to show the user
something quickly you know to hide that
load in the background if it's not the
first level level of gameplay then at
least some kind of loading bar or
something for the user to see and engage
with as they're as they're waiting and
it's always a good idea to test early
and often especially on device and
especially across both Android 7 and
Android 8 because the instant app
runtime is actually implemented
differently on each of those OS versions
and you can have bugs on one and not the
other so it's important to keep that in
mind and you know submitting an early
build to the play console under the
internal or or alpha track will really
help because it'll surface errors early
you can you kind of want to get those
under wraps and you want to get them
fixed as quickly as possible because you
don't want to wait till your game is
about to hit production and there's some
weird error that gets surfaced to you
right as you're trying to to submit and
it's always a good idea to write your
game in a flexible way ideally you can
make it data-driven this especially
applies if you're working on a brand new
game it really helps because you know
it's it's easier to restructure the app
for when you do an instant game because
it's usually pretty different product
wise from the full thing and in our
experience several third-party SDKs were
only partially compatible with instant
apps this is a situation that's always
improving and it's probably vastly
different from when we started but you
know it's never a bad idea to
check your third-party dependencies and
you know since nobody likes writing
duplicate code if you can share it with
your main app it's always a good idea
you also get the benefit of free access
to any updates made to your main game
we'll just filter down into the instant
game so that's pretty much all I had
thank you
if you have any questions happy to
answer hi thanks for the talk
I'm just wondering if you can or anyone
from Google can share any like stats on
like how that improves their stall rate
of fill funnel that is unfortunately
it's the only thing I can't talk about
you can actually see you know the stats
of installs from the store directly or
and separated from the ones through in
sales my yeah if you if you look at
Google's developer Day keynote
presentation at GDC I believe they did
talk about that a little bit and they
talked about for the early launch
partners kind of what lifts you know
they all got there's also going to be
another talk Aquila where they're gonna
share more this information thank you
you said you stripped out some of the
bug reporting architectures are you
still getting some bug reporting are you
still having metrics on yeah losing the
instrument yeah we left one and turns
out there was more than one and are you
still able to gather metrics from like
within the instant play mm-hmm yep these
are you know they're standard or they're
pretty much just like normal apps you
can run all those libraries and get the
same data so my Samsung Galaxy s8
doesn't show the try now any idea why
that might be for which game forwards
with friends - I think I know why that
is okay that's a bug that just surfaced
last week but yeah it normally does so
it might show up in another week or so
if if you actually yes if you if you
actually send yourself an email to the
URL that we used to our games page
forwards with friends and you click on
that link in you know for example your
Gmail app or something it will actually
launch the app that way as well you
don't need to be on the Play Store to
launch these things you can actually
launch them from anywhere you you can
click a link right now instant game
doesn't work on a 2 0 to 0 we or Galaxy
s8 is probably eight zero zero Android
version so you need to wait for an
update to 8 or 12 also make sure that
instant apps are enabled
which they they should be by defaults I
think yeah so with your instant app with
unity did you actually make a separate
app because you're sharing the game code
and that's of stuff because they were
talking about stripping out that many
libraries did you actually make a
separate app for it or did you do a
subset of its it's an extreme subset
it's it's basically it's sharing the
same code it's branched but you know the
the it outputs like a completely
separate apk okay so you use a different
builds because I do a lot of shared
build systems that stuff is I used to
separate build kind of flow for that
instant app with unity right so yeah in
the game we had an extremely customized
build script and we just kind of
extended that for the instant app target
the strength to understand the
connection between the instant app and
the app you installed later like if you
want to persist your data save game data
from one to another what are the
mechanisms there so on Android 8 it's
automatic it actually it shares the same
app container on the device so you
there's like an API called show install
prompt you call that and the user clicks
install and the app gets the full app
gets downloaded and installed and they
use whatever user data you stored in the
instant app container will be available
to the main app just as if it was put
there by the game itself and on Android
7 I believe there's a migration API that
you can call okay thank you